oh my god this is getting borderline
meta
my brain hey everyone i'm abby sharp
welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today i am a full week into fighting one
of the many viruses that my family
brings in the doors
[Music]
but i thought we would have a little fun
and do something unique you know since
you guys are so used to seeing me review
other creators whatever days why not
revisit
one of my own
so today i'm going to be looking back a
year ago in time and reviewing my old
what i eat in a day but first let me
tell you about my sponsor bill barr so i
am always looking for creative ways to
bump up the satiety factor in my meals
and snacks and build bars have been such
a fun and delicious way to check that
box these bars are unique because they
taste like chocolate bars because
they're made with real chocolate while
being packed with protein and flavor so
today's variety
what do i feel like when i'm sick
i mean let's go back to the childhood
comfort flavors
cookies and cream this my friends is a
pick me up and just because i've lost my
voice doesn't mean i've lost my moves
[Music]
and 70 grams of protein come on we love
that we love to see it obviously you can
enjoy these alone for a quick snack or
add them to another snack like oatmeal
yogurt fruit or smoothie for a larger
snack or meal i love all the flavor
options and they're always innovating
something new so if you want to try out
build bar yourself check out the link in
my description and use my promo code
abbiesharp15 to get 15 off of your order
and you can pause the screen or look at
the description to check out my general
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating as
always please feel free to skip this
video if it's not supportive to your
journey and if you are not already
subscribed what are you doing hit that
sub button and follow me over on tick
tock and instagram abby's kitchen all
right a quick little recap on where i
was at this point in my life this video
that we're going to review was published
at the end of june 2021 and was shot
probably early may 2021 i was a ripe 33
year old with a three-year-old and a
nine-month-old at home just like trying
to figure out how to work and parent a
year into the pandemic no big deal it
was a struggle but i was still pumping
in the night and breastfeeding regularly
in the day but i was starting to think
about ways that i could improve my ibs
and my sleep and i don't know like just
my general quality of life because at
this point like i was struggling with
the concept of self-care maybe i still
am do you know but i had basically just
worked with my colleague on a low fodmap
elimination trial to see what my
symptoms were and my triggers were but i
actually didn't test positive for sibo
until a month or so later i also hadn't
started any sleep medication for my
insomnia or my anxiety so let's take a
look at what i ate in a day and how
things have changed since then i guess i
didn't film my first meal of the day
because it occurred at like 2 a.m while
i was pumping and pitch black so yeah
doesn't make for the best food porn but
i literally wake up starving and very
thirsty in the middle of the night so i
like shovel dry cereal into my mouth
before i fall back asleep so as a
pumping and a nursing mom i would be
up in the night literally burning
calories so it's very common for
breastfeeding moms to like need a
midnight snack if you want to make the
food you gotta eat the food now i'm no
longer breastfeeding an infant at night
or at all but instead i am often awake
at 2 a.m just like thinking about a
random conversation that i had a week
back with a stranger i'm just like what
do you look like
stranger and if i haven't had a
substantial enough bedtime snack i can
actually start to feel hunger creep in
and that kind of [ __ ] with my sleep
even more unfortunately what i've
learned from a lot of trial and error is
that eating even a small snack in the
middle of the night significantly throws
off my digestion the next morning
literally my whole bathroom routine goes
to
no pun intended likely because giving
the body a nice long fast overnight
helps the migratory motor complex do its
natural cleansing job so very quickly
the migratory motor complex is like a
big sweeping broom that moves food along
the digestive tract every 90 to 130
minutes or so every time we put anything
with calories in our mouth it halts the
mmc and it's forced to kind of start the
process all over again and if we aren't
allowing this mmc to occur in full
bacteria can more easily pool and
therefore flourish so it's often
theorized that constantly disrupting the
mmc can contribute to conditions that
cause sibo and that folks with sibo have
a compromised mmc so knowing about my
sibo journey now i do try to focus on
having a really satiating snack plus my
fiber supplement before bed at night
just to help provide that extra staying
power throughout the night i have been
managing to sleep until like 5 30
sometimes 6 a.m
thanks to making some serious efforts to
you know better prioritize my mental and
physical health and get a little bit of
better work and life balance ugh it is
low-key depressing that my sleep was
better then despite having to be like
woken up at 1am to pump every night and
now my kids sleep well through the night
i'm heavily medicated and i'm still a
mess she's a hot mess
and that's it is this what adulting is
but for my first little meal of the day
i'm having some plain full fat greek
yogurt with some freeze-dried fruit okay
i love this pre-breakfast snack here
we've got protein fat and a bit of fiber
and carbs and as a breastfeeding mom i
remember that i absolutely needed that
extra meal first thing in the morning
when i woke up to fuel my body so that i
could feel my sun feeding o and just
getting through another day with a
toddler at home in a pandemic was 100
my priority over worrying about how much
time i gave my gut to digest overnight
or between meals however at this point
in my life and my sibo recovery where
i've eradicated the bacteria and i'm
kind of in like a maintenance mode i do
try to have larger meals four to five
hours apart and a longer 12 hour stretch
overnight and while of course knew about
the importance of meal spacing and the
migratory motor complex at the time
fueling myself more often for milk
production was obviously my primary goal
all right now once they are set i tag it
out with my hubby and i try to get a
quick little workout in so i've got the
peloton app so i am doing lots of
workouts through that and i also train
with two different trainers a few times
a week on zoom oh man i don't miss
breastfeeding but i desperately miss my
breastfeeding boobs cool a boob oh wait
there's a baby on it food boob it's
called breastfeeding when people call
post baby boobs pancakes it is not fake
news appreciate what you got well you
got it when i'm feeling like having just
like a straight-up bowl of cereal but i
want to make it more satisfying i add a
little protein powder to the milk which
kind of flavors the milk and then also
boosts up the protein and then i will
just add in whatever cereal i feel like
so today i did a mixture of cheerios and
puffins and then i'm just serving that
up with some peanut butter toast with
some banana and a little crunchy granola
and some hemp hearts and honey and some
extra fruit on the side tell me that
doesn't look
delicious okay i love this breakfast i
love that i got protein in the protein
powder fiber-rich carbs in the cereal
toast fruit and granola and healthy fats
with the nut butter and hemp hearts i do
recall that at the time of this i was
using a protein powder that was
sweetened with splenda which i later
learned was likely a pretty big trigger
for me blenda or sucralose
is something that's often suggested that
we try to dramatically reduce during
sibo recovery so now i typically stick
to supplements with monk fruit stevia or
real sugar all right one more coffee but
make a decaf again my health priorities
have clearly shifted over the past year
so dramatically that a lot of these
little morning rituals have also changed
so when i was breastfeeding and pumping
in the night i had a lot more prolactin
in my body which is a hormone that helps
promote relaxation and sleep in fact one
study comparing breastfeeding moms with
formula feeding moms found that the
breastfeeding moms got more restful
nighttime sleep so both times when i was
newly postpartum i could have a coffee
as late as like mid afternoon if i
wanted to and i'd fall asleep just fine
these days my brain is sensitive as f
and it just doesn't get those sleepy
cues very easily i basically now have a
like super strict coffee cutoff of like
10 am but of course my eventual long
time goal is to have a more normal
relationship with sleep so that i can be
more flexible with things like coffee
and other insomnia triggers because yeah
coffee is and always will be my favorite
part of the day uh slapped on some
store-bought hummus and some prosciutto
added in some chopped cucumbers and
tomatoes and spinach and i smashed that
chicken in there and i served it with
some of the ninja vegetables that tried
to escape from my sandwich so yeah i
shovel that in with the kids so that's
why you're not seeing me because i'm
eating with my children so funny story i
can't eat that italy soup anymore
because i got a stomach bug after eating
it one day and i like puked it all up
and now just the smell alone is hella
triggering leave me a comment below if
cygnus has ruined a perfectly delicious
food for you otherwise i would totally
crush a meal like that today i love that
we've got healthy fats in the hummus
protein in the chicken carbs in the wrap
and tons of veg and i 100 agree that
cooked veg and soups are always going to
be easier on the gut than raw though
it's kind of funny to me that i was
dedicated enough to eat all my
vegetables cooked in soup to make them
easier to digest but i didn't think
twice about slathering on the hummus i
can now eat small amounts of hummus in
moderation but when i had untreated sibo
even a smear would send me like ripon
all the way to fart city all night long
not good
in retrospect i would probably do like
pesto or guacamole instead if for no
other reason than to like save my
marriage i also now try to do larger
sit-down meals so again if i were
serving myself this today i'd probably
throw in a piece of fruit with some nut
butter just for a little extra carbs and
fat to carry me through until dinner one
day i won't have to stress shovel soup
into my mouth
oh yeah all my parents know what i'm
talking about when i say that mindful
eating is a legit joke when you've got
young kids we know that eating quickly
is one of the most common reasons for
gas bloating and indigestion since your
food needs that deliberate time in the
mouth to break down larger pieces of
food and release digestive enzymes
inhaling food also results in the
gulping of air which can also exacerbate
trapped gas but i want to point out that
my rush early motherhood eating habits
did not cause my sibo doing four
back-to-back rounds of antibiotics for
five bouts of mastitis while
breastfeeding likely caused my sibo not
surprisingly though all of those
stressed meals and my stressed body and
my stressed mind all made it a lot worse
the early days of motherhood are
generally a cluster
and with two kids and a career to
balance in a pandemic i would really
only ever get moments to like shovel
something in so i have complete empathy
for my former self i was just doing the
best job that i could now that my kids
are four and two family meals are
definitely still like a rush slash
struggle but they're at least out of the
house for like my breakfast and my lunch
time so i can sit down with some
semblance of peace i also had to put a
little snack
so i had some leftover edamame and some
chopped up mango with tajin
which is the most delicious seasoning
mix ever oh man that looked like a
perfect mango and this reminds me how
hard it felt at first to go from like
regular snacking to square meals i've
been a grazer and a snack queen my whole
life and i stand by the fact that
snacking is really important for a lot
of people it was definitely really
important for me during this time in my
life when my nutrient needs were so high
so when my dietitian and i decided i was
going to try to meal space to optimize
my sibo protocol it was definitely a
strange adjustment i had to relearn my
body's needs at a meal to ensure that i
wasn't accidentally under eating and
this was a real process sometimes i'd
undershoot it and need to have a snack
or an earlier dinner and sometimes i
would overshoot and i'd feel
uncomfortably full this is all part of
my personal intuitive eating journey
because it was done from a place of
self-care nourishment and symptom
management rather than body manipulation
and restriction in fact
once i psychologically got into the
habit of sitting down to larger meals i
actually felt a heightened sense of food
freedom it meant that i was interrupted
by hunger and therefore the need to like
plan and think about another meal or
snack fewer times in the day i basically
ended up with more space in my brain to
think about things other than food and
even though i love food that experience
has been really really freeing
this is such an easy meal but i also
remember my kids hated it canned lentils
while convenient sometimes they just
have like a muddy flavor so i'm pretty
sure that the kids just ate plain pasta
and bread that day and that is totally
all i can expect or hope for them to do
i mean we always make sure to have one
or more safe foods on the table that the
kids know that they can fill up on even
when they're not feeling like being
adventurous or trying something new it's
rich in casein protein which is a slow
digesting protein
so i basically like to top mine off with
some berries almonds and chocolate chips
you guys know that as the hunger
crushing combo so i still regularly eat
cottage cheese before bed because the
casein protein is a slow digesting
protein that keeps you fuller longer and
promotes muscle recovery overnight so
it's definitely been a favorite bedtime
snack in the fitness world but again
because i'm no longer having that
pre-breakfast breakfast and because my
insomnia often can cause me to get
hungry in the night and then throw off
my digestion if i do have a midnight
snack i now focus on having a much
larger bedtime snack and this isn't
exactly a pattern of eating i would
recommend for everyone because we do
have evidence for health benefits
associated with like front loading
calories as opposed to having more at
night but because of my unique sleep and
digestive nutrition related goals this
is the routine that i've just found now
works best for me so in summary i feel
like this offers a little extra insight
into how when nutrition goals or
priorities change diet can change along
with it and making changes to your diet
a routine can absolutely be compatible
with intuitive eating when they come
from a place of self-care what worked
for me back in 2021 was different than
what's working for me now and what i'm
doing now probably wouldn't have worked
then not because i couldn't have
benefited from meal spacing or like a
larger bedtime snack but because i just
didn't have the emotional bandwidth to
even think about it and that's okay one
thing i've learned as a practicing
dietitian and a dietitian's client is
that we need to meet people where they
are there is no point in trying to
change your diet to improve your
physical health if it's going to cost
you your emotional health insanity we're
all just doing the best job that we can
so on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today thank you for bearing
with me with my compromised voice here
if you like this video be sure to give
it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below with your thoughts and what you'd
like to see me cover next subscribe to
the channel and i will see you next time
on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]